[Music]
yeah good to go chen welcome monday
morning march 28th it is the morning
here in los angeles rainy guys it's
rainy out there and if you're not from
la when it rains people think the the
tires on their car are going to melt off
so they drive like dummies so that's
cool
traffic is terrible when it rains it's
the way it goes what's your sign up for
shout out to la
shout out to chicago your boys fresh off
the plane from chicago
where um i linked up with my boy matt
uh matt is a photographer you will see
matt uh he took the pictures right there
tin yeah that's me and uh my boy george
uh but matt is a uh
photographer and he was the his um
matt was a guy probably seven years ago
my first star we did find the kid live
at the vic theater out in chicago he
came along was just like he just got out
of college like trying to find his way
and then uh probably two three years
into knowing him he'd always shoot my
shows he'd fly into the when i was on
tour you met matt
and uh he's a swaggy dude but he um
he just freaking blew up man now he's
the personal photographer gucci man he
like works with him every single weekend
he uh you know he works with asap rocky
and little wayne he's just
he's just crushing it man and it's just
a kid with a talent and does a lot of
freaking dope dope stuff man he has some
insane stories about working with those
guys and going to magic city within the
strip club and dude his pictures
literally uh say a thousand words it's
he's he's the best so linked up with my
boy matt
out there there he is
multi mars is his name um yeah he's a
swaggy dude he's in a fashion shoe so
we're all into the same stuff
great dude though um yeah
met up with george harris who's the
newest edition of thick boy
network
uh you guys would know george he was on
king the sting
uh
welcome to the show george that's
hilarious um that's from brian callum so
george uh i don't know how how long ago
over a year and a half ago calling king
this thing is 480 pounds he's like yo
man i'm a thick boy you know you
motivate me to work out and you know
he's just a fan of
the the whole squad brian theo chris
everybody chen everybody and uh he goes
i'm gonna get down to 190.
and i said my man and so this is a kid
who has every reason not to
you know not to be as happy as he is you
know his family has a history of
addiction and people have passed away
and you know some of his close family
members uh have uh addiction stuff like
that and he takes care of his mom who
has uh you know some sort of issue so
this kid has all the reasons the world
uh to not
kind of be a happy go lucky person but
he just has this energy about him
and he's never left uh illinois he lives
right outside illinois about i'm sorry
right outside chicago he lives about an
hour outside chicago in the the suburbs
it's tough where he lives so he calls in
and goes on 480 pounds and he goes my
goal is to get down to 190.
so clearly that is a ton of weight that
is highly unpopular unlikely
so he he mentions he's never been on
plane or stay in a hotel
and uh i go my man you get down to 190
i'll fly you out to la and put you on
king the sting is all right say less
probably a year and change later i mean
we had some updates you know still
looking thick you know
and then the dude got down to 190.
insane dude 190 through just hard work
and diet he had a keto diet
and uh we flew him to l.a he uh wrestled
uh stevie and actually stevie beat the
brakes off of him but that's okay stevie
did not take it easy on him and stevie
we did not know has a pretty um
extensive wrestling background and
really beat the [ __ ] out of george but
that was not the
you know
not didn't get george down didn't get
our boy georgie down so uh
yeah georgie's just this kid has this
energy about him and he's just such a
great story just such a great person so
he started doing little things for thick
boy little things on the channel and
social and stuff like that and just a
loyal dude and he's on it man and big
mike who's the head of uh thick boy
networks here production wise uh i was
like man this george kid he's thirsty
man he's trying to get work in i went
really he goes yeah man he's he learns
everything i'd send him he picks up and
he's working hard and he's on it
checking in all the time it's an
interesting thing he goes yeah man i
think we got a loyal dude here i said
yeah he's a good dude
so time goes by still losing weight he
loses any more weight it's gonna be
trouble and
you know we decided i guess uh mike
asked that mike has extra room in his
house where he stays in studio city he
goes what do you think if george came
out here for an internship i said i'd
love that man said is george into i know
his family stuff like that
and uh george accepted the the gig so
george do an interim ship which
hopefully turns into a full-time gig
here at thick boy and uh i told him
about it when i was out in chicago in
front of his mom his mom is super
nervous about it she was like you know
don't let my son do this i said lady
listen man
the whole crew is boring here
the guy he's staying with collects
trading cards
okay
he collects trading cards and you tell
him how many movies he's worked on trust
me
love you mike but i said trust me uh
he's he's gonna be good he's he's gonna
be well taken care of so george uh is
driving from chicago to l.a starts may
1st man driving
what a dope story though man just such a
good person
yeah just a great kid
just a great freaking kid man
so shout out to georgie dude you're
doing the goddamn thing we're proud of
you man no matter what happens we're all
super proud of you
but uh
yeah chicago one of my favorite cities
man there's just so much rich history
there great food i cheated on my diet
not crazy i had one slice of
what chicago calls pizza i call lasagna
i had one thick slice of their deep dish
pizza
and i like it saucy i had literally one
slice i posted it on my story i think
it's not there anymore but i posted my
story it's just so cheesy so saucy
now
you know i cheated a little on my
birthday nothing crazy didn't have any
bread or anything like that i think i
had
maybe a spoonful of ice cream nothing
crazy i haven't cheated and [ __ ] i don't
know man a hot second that's why boys
down and wait
i just feel good you know it's the
easiest diet event to stick to being on
carnivore
so i ate that deep dish pizza thursday
night after the show dude it
wrecked my world it wrecked my world my
[ __ ] was singing all weekend long
doug
my stomach was not right for i mean
still not great you know it was tough
not doing that again chicago thank you
for having me but that is not my thing i
just i don't know you just can't do it
like that anymore i just can't live that
life anymore and thank god
um
face will stay fat that's whatever but
um
yeah shout out to chicago man
especially where i'm at uh is the
schomburg improv i keep saying chicago
it's about 45 minutes outside chicago
so it's not technically chicago um
especially the tickets we sold i think
probably i'll do the vic theater next
time
that's probably the move for me moving
forward but uh schaumburg was fantastic
man great shows we had a local host
there they have a great comedy scene
there
so usually i
unplug and play the club don't have to
worry about anything i bring my own
opener two features of myself that's why
i do my brother sells the merch
it's plug and play they don't have to do
anything but lately what i've been doing
if in certain markets that are known for
good
comics you know i want to give everybody
an opportunity as much as i can so i let
them book the host so they booked a
local chicago guy he was great in
nashville they booked the kid the kid we
showed the uh
remember the he was the doctor with the
eye thing
oh that thing yeah yeah yeah so you know
it's hit or miss certain certain mark
like you got a certain market where
comedy's not their thing
it gets dicey but it's also hilarious
when they'll host bombs it makes for a
fun weekend so
uh shout out chicago man had a great
time told you guys come with the fire
with that jacket like complex uh complex
con jacket chicago jacket by a japanese
designer that thing was a hit and i will
be wearing it way more than just at the
shows this guy goes i need that jacket
please and thank you right dude right i
also saved probably my most expensive
kicks as well for chicago
now cop did come we have a bunch of cops
coming to the shows right also i'm super
pro blue super pro blue matter of fact i
go to new york in may for pr but i'm
going to chicago on tour in december
which will be announced soon i've been
there forever i'm gonna link up with
nypd i'm do a tour of the
main kind of what he called station
there but i think there's something cool
we could do with nypd blue they could
really use it man yeah but a bunch of
cops come so the whole point of that
story is
the cop you know he's a sneaker head
he's been on the force for 30 years in
chicago he's working the south side
chicago you know where it's tough and uh
he goes hey man be careful wearing those
shoes around chicago oh i said oh i'm
not a dummy dude i'm not gonna wear
these around town i literally just wear
them when i'm driving to schaumburg and
he goes yeah but your posts on social
media okay and he goes and i go but
they know if they want to find me at
schomburg you know come get these hands
man whatever you want to do and he goes
no it's not about that he's there's some
wild boys in chicago he goes you do
postmates in uber right
i know yeah of course i do he's getting
airbnb postmaster uber he goes those
guys know he knows i'm sure that some
recognizer yeah all the time he goes
yeah man and they see your social media
you gotta be careful i'm like what
um maybe i'm just a raging freaking
[ __ ] boy could not sl after he told me
that i could not sleep then that we we
got an older airbnb and it was like loud
the whole night i was up just thinking
someone's gonna come in and jack my
jordans you know
but um yeah shout out to all the cops
keep coming the shows man i got you guys
man
i got you guys
um but yeah chicago is fantastic man
chicago is great got some great friends
out there they have great restaurants
man so much history here's the thing
about the cubs too
people be able to relate to this when i
the it doesn't make any sense i'm a cubs
fan people always ask me why are you a
cubs fan why kept saying well because
when i was a kid
um colorado didn't have a team to like
93
so grow i think the rockies and marlins
came in 93 94 maybe 96.97 i forget bring
that up jim i wish we had a computer
like that stuff i was on it um
but um when i was a kid i'd rush home
from school because the only uh games
that were on was wgn
so 1991
the rockies founded is that when they
started
the team's player
so i was eight but we didn't grow up
with a baseball team really it was kind
of a big deal when they came
but um
yeah 991 so uh yeah i've been eight but
i'd rush home from school
all the time because uh on wgn which was
national syndicated
tv the cubs were always on so that was a
team i grew up watching more than
anybody more than in baseball so i just
grew up a cubs fan
and i did this before
off white started messing with cubs
logos and dropping gear which obviously
uh rest in peace virgil but
i would always wear a cubs hat the blue
standard cups hat and i took a uh a
white sharpie uh drew paw prints all
over the bill so it looked like a little
cub locked on it it was lit everybody
wanted me to their hats but they didn't
have cubs hats so i wouldn't do it so i
was the only one with it fly back in the
day even back in the day as flight but
point is i grew up a cubs fan
obviously a huge broncos fan they were
always on a nuggets fan but my baseball
team even over the rockies has always
been the cubs because of ryan sandberg
mark grace sammy sosa like they just had
a squad uh andrew dawson because that's
up i'd rush home and just watch the cubs
at wrigley field man that was the squad
they were on tv that's who i liked you
know so to this day that's my team which
is very strange shout out to wgn and
then harry kerry remember him herrick
right he was the announcer as a kid that
[ __ ] was lit i get my dunkaroose dude a
[ __ ] full thing of coca-cola just all
the sugar i could handle and watch
[ __ ] ryan sandberg dominate you
kidding me i was trying to buy a ryan
sandberg jersey they had one but
it was the new one with ryan sam i want
the old school ryan sandberg jersey if
anybody knows where i can get that
holler at your boy man i'm trying to
find that
i bet my boys at uh suplex philly can
find it
you put sandberg and it's sandberg and
that kind of drives me nuts orion
ryan ryan sandberg dude
well there's one jesus 80 bucks
oh there's uh see so you see
uh
that
is that one autographed
autograph that one see i want yeah the
wow yeah
yeah that'd be the one that i need chin
that one i love the the pinstripe is my
favorite though that one yeah that's
what i need for you
that's what i need 300 bucks might have
to go ahead and buy that even though how
much is this one chin which one um go
down one yeah yeah yeah click on that
for me click on that
that's what i need 2.99
that's what i need
they have my size
god damn only a small only a small 36.
that's rude dude
everyone wants that ryan sandburg jersey
i wonder what he's up to man what a stud
what a stud but shout out to chicago
i'll find the ryan sandburg georgie on
my off time okay we don't have to do it
on air right now
um but yeah shout out to chicago next up
i got two weeks off from the road i'll
be doing shows around l.a next shop and
friends is at the hollywood improv april
6th that's a wednesday we have some
monsters again you know this man let's
make this our eighth sold out show in a
row that's the hollywood improv one show
one night only 8 p.m shop and friends at
the hollywood improv april 6
but back the thick boy tour continues in
phoenix arizona stand up live one of my
favorite spots in the world phoenix
arizona stand up live april 14th through
the 16th
and i will be uh and i will argue with
anybody in the world you think you have
good wings in your town there's not a
better chicken wing on this planet not
magic city not buffalo wild wings get
all that [ __ ] out of my face there's
no better wings than jt's wings in
phoenix arizona it's right outside i
think i think it's called paradise
valley it's right outside there it is
fantastic
and they're setting the boys up we're
going to go there on saturday
if you want to meet the squad we'll
probably be the round noon
eating all the wings killing so many
chickens we think about so many chickens
die
whatever uh then after that april 22nd
through the 23rd is austin texas moon
tower festival your boy is one of the
headliners the moon tower festival it's
at the new cap cities out there um
that's two shows friday two shows
saturday the squad is in full effect
then you got phoenix i'm sorry philly
one of my favorite spots phillies may
19th through 21st
tickets at thickboy.com or
fatkz.com get you some let's take a
little break from me ranting your ear
off about fighting uh because man
sometimes i can't sleep man i know a lot
of y'all struggle sleeping and you you
look like you got nuts under your eyes
you can't sleep look at me look at my
eyes man i'm getting a lot of sleep
someone's keeping you up
maybe it's anxiety of the politics right
now of things going on outside the world
maybe can't sleep because will smith
slap chris rock and you're upset about
it and maybe it's just your terrible
mattress you ever think about that might
be a really crappy mattress that's one
of my friends at helix sleep they got
you covered man because you just don't
want to sleep on any mattress you want
one built just for your thick self helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress just for you what do
you like it soft firm sleep on your side
your back you sleep hot you sleep cold
helix sleep we take all that in
consideration and we give you the best
mattress ever i have in my crib i can't
get my friends to leave i can't get my
in-laws to leave family's always trying
to come out here and i was like oh i
guess they like me know they like my
helix sleep mattresses that's what they
like just go to helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with the perfect
mattress to give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
all right and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free all right
but they'll pick it up if you don't love
it but you will so don't worry about
that helix sleep is offering you guys up
to 200 off all mattress orders and free
pillows for the listeners and viewers of
the shop show helixsleep.com
that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200 off
yo man i know i'm getting older because
i care about my lawn i care about a
green lawn i care that my ficuses are
popping and springs almost here it's
getting hot in la i know the rest of you
listening around the world it's getting
hot where you're at man and there's
nothing like feeling soft green grass
underneath your feet man and thankfully
the friends at sunday get your lawn
grown and helps to keep it healthy all
season long all right maybe you're
worried about all the chemicals you keep
using right you're like man this isn't
good my kids play out there how about
this traditional lawn care lays down 90
million pounds of pesticides each year
sunday is different they're on a mission
to change how people care for their
yards all right they're completely
different man you don't have to worry
about your family running out there
barefoot i got a two and six year old i
don't want pesticides and chemicals all
up on their little feet while they're
running around to come back inside you
know what i'm saying it's not good man
it's not good sunday can help you grow a
beautiful lawn without the guesswork or
the nasty chemicals their custom plant
include fertilizer and everything you
need to easily care for your lawn with
ingredients like seaweed iron molasses
you can feel good with the kids and pets
being around playing all over your
freaking green grass the neighbors gonna
be all jealous of your green grass you
know your dad when you care about grass
man all right so make the neighbors
jealous this year all right all you have
to do is visit getsunday.com put in your
address and their lawn analysis tool
does the rest they then use the soil and
climate data to create a personal
nutrient plan delivered to your door
when you need it this is what's dope
about it your boy uses it here all the
time my ficuses are jumanji style just
attach ready to use pouch to a garden
hose and spray away takes 15 minutes or
less best of all this stuff works check
out your boys lawn i have it on my
instagram story my line's popping when
you see my kids on that lawn it's green
as hell and sunday's offering you guys
the shop show viewers and listeners 20
off full season plans are just 129 bucks
you get 20 off at checkout when you
visit getsunday.com
shop20 that's 20 off your custom planet
get sunday yes sunday like the day
getsunday.com20.
we had fights over the weekend man we
had some fights over the weekend i got
to watch the entire card yesterday
uh really just the main card
you know i told you guys after uh london
fight night this one's gonna be tough to
live up to it because there's a lot of
hype around that london card you know
it's especially being shut down in uh
england for what two years and being the
first card and they they that could have
been a pay-per-view easily and they
really showed out so you know ohio
columbus had a lot to live up to
curtis blades definitely passed the test
um but if you have to give mvp it's
kaicara france by far so kaiker of
france completely deserves a title shot
now you got brian moreno and uh figorito
fighting again is the fourth time fourth
which
i have no argument there that's fine but
kaiker of france is for sure your next
uh title contender and he should
definitely fight for the title so he's
coming off remember he knocked out uh
cody garbrandt there's no punk obviously
cut down to 125 and did the damn thing
but kaiker of france knocked him out
you're talking about former champ
and then uh you know beating asgarov
who's undefeated no loss in the ufc
you know good fight too he definitely
enjoys the title shot so he lost spray
moreno unanimous decision lost to bran
uh royvall uh submission which is tough
one but that was also fight of the night
so his and then in his last three he's
had
two out of three performance of the
ninth
no punk man he's no punk definitely just
without a shot hopefully he gets it man
also he'd be good to get some fresh
blood in there he's gonna be a tough
customer to beat now
i mean i know brandon moreno beat him a
hot second ago but still
uh brian barbarina shout out to brian
barbarina going into columbus and
beating matt brown's no joke man split
decision i thought matt might have got
it glad my our boy brian got the win
that was your fight of the night alexa
grazo did the goddamn thing in the first
round she definitely catapulted herself
in the flight division then curtis
blades chris dawkis
poor chris man so chris dawkis uh one of
philly's finest you guys know i again i
write for the the the black and blue out
there uh former cop
you know he gets uh he he's
his brother's a monster too so you got
two of philly's finest doing the goddamn
thing in the ufc
you know
the heavyweight division is tough man
because you win a couple fights and then
you're catapulted to the to the top
slots so he goes on this win streak and
then they go cool here is derek lewis
didn't go his way gets knocked out
which didn't make sense to me because
you get beat by derrick lewis and they
go oh that's cool he wasn't even worse
man curtis blades
so it didn't make a lot of sense you
know the division's kind of tied up
right with francis having his
surgery and then you got sepe waiting in
the in the wings and he got
freaking jon jones
you know supposedly coming back which i
pray to god he does so the division is a
little weird so i guess that's why they
did it you got tied to avasa and clearly
got tom aspinall you know raging from
london trying to get into the
conversation so
i guess the fight makes sense keep
curtis blades busy i don't think they
know what to do with them so for curtis
blades to to get a big win like this 17
seconds second round
gets on the mic does a great promo says
he wants a title shot next i don't think
he gets it i think we're getting jon
jones stipe stephen was in the crowd uh
obviously he's from there well he's from
cleveland but um
you know i think her displayed stipe
would make a lot of sense i just don't
see it happening i think you know jon
jones and steve will get announced and
we're going to get that some time in the
summer so for curtis blades a cyril god
makes a lot of sense depends how much
they like cyril gone i don't see sirogon
winning that fight i think chris blade
gets around the second or third round
curtis blades is just such a freaking
monster man he's a monster and he'll
beat you know 99.9 of the roster and
could be your champ depending on the
night you know i think if he fights
francis
or uh you know
derek lewis you know he can beat those
guys i think that fight
half the time if they fight ten times
goes uh his way so i i do think he can
be champ it's just depends what dfc
wants to do with him he's a little bit
of an awkward guy i think that maybe
that's what's going on obviously his
ground and pound is vicious
um they just got to figure out what they
want to do with them it's all about
you know you look at the heavyweight
division
you look at the you know sarah god had
his chance didn't happen he's not the
most exciting fighter either sirogon's a
complete
nightmare as a match-up with his
athletic ability and striking but he's
you know he's not the most exciting guy
he looks the part but you know
not great on the mic so it depends what
they want to do you got tied to avasa
there who has personality for days
so depending on what they want to do
with thai
depending what they want to do with
curse blades depend what they want to do
with tom aspinall you could have tom
blades or tai to ivasa your next champ
depending who the ufc likes more
to me that's interesting because it's
all about match-ups at the heavyweight
you know especially in the top
six it's all about match-ups if they
want tom to be their champ there you
know you don't give tom curtis blades
you don't give tai two of us at curtis
blades curtis beats both of those guys
probably
now tom asmal matches up better against
him but be a tough night in the office
for tom so it depends what they want to
do if you want curtis champ there's a
way to to get it done
and then obviously if he gets to the
title shot there's nothing we can do
he's going to fight either jon jones or
stipe depend who's the interim champ out
of that but
if they want curtis plays to be champ
there's a there's a route that can take
they want ty to have us to be champ
there's a route you can take there's tom
aspinall if they want to bank on the you
know english market in the european
market we can do that too
but you'll you'll find out pretty
quickly who they want to be the face of
the heavyweight division with francis
being gone for nine months
depending on the next matchups if you
see tom vs curtis blades they don't want
tom to be your their world champ if you
see tai tuavasa
curtis blades they they don't want ty to
be their champ it's curtis blades so
you know
that's part of the game it is the the
entertainment business especially when
talking about the heavyweight division
but
i don't think it's going to matter
because it's going to be jon jones stipe
winner that's going to be your interim
heavyweight champ and there's going to
be waiting for francis gano in the in
the wings there so
chris blades you know he's in a
i don't want to say a tough spot but
it's his his career is
based upon what the ufc wants them to do
it's all about matchups same with tom
asmal same with tai tuvavasa i would
love tai to ivasa versus tom aspinall it
just sucks because curtis blades trains
with my former team they tell me how
much of a monster he is how he's gonna
be champ and we haven't seen anything
what how how talented he is inside the
outgun even now so we'll see neil magni
getting the job done i thought he was
about to get his ass what that doesn't
get knocked out that was not going well
for him and then he kind of pulled it
off but you know and then neil magna i
think calls out hamza he's been calling
him out for a long time yeah yeah i just
you know i don't like that fight for
kneeling any faster i don't like that
fight for anybody but especially my
friend neil magni but um
it's i don't think it's happening
because what happened is hamzat
leapfrogged him right so that fights
ain't going to happen if neil wins like
two more i could see it happening but uh
hamza obviously has this fight
against uh
gilbert yep gilbert burns which i think
he passed that test and then
it's gonna be tough for neil to touch
that shooting star that dagger standing
swedish shooting star it's gonna be very
tough for him to catch him
uh outside that and i told you guys the
best car of the weekend goes one
championship one championship by far had
the most entertaining
fights uh this past weekend why'd i tell
you about dj i mean listen you don't
have to be some mma savant to think dj
could survive
around with this complete badass muay
thai and he survives it i don't give a
[ __ ] what uh rutang is doing in thailand
and grappling in the sand and doing all
that [ __ ] you know all his
hype videos was him you know grappling
and stuff like that he ain't stopping dj
from getting you down choking you out
and i i called it to a tee second round
rear naked choke
but that was the easy call angela lee
was a little trouble early on i think
that's just ring rust you know she did
have a kid
um but that's stamp fair tax she's fun
huh she's a fun one to watch anjali is
such a badass then akiyama
our boy sexy yama getting it done dude
getting it done got it done yeah
a fight of uh the japanese legends you
got it done and then i hate to see it
but at least he went out on a shield
john wayne parr didn't get his 100th win
but still
went out on shield man came out strong
to him through that no man yeah yeah
first second was a little dicey and
third you know really turned it on so
shout out to john white park sure legend
freaking legend man what do you got jeff
want to see some highlights real quick
of the one championship so this is
actually dj doing damn well with his
muay thais
yes i like dj just oh [ __ ]
it's not like dj's just running
and of course he went to sleep he's not
to happen no that guy's crazy
all right and also we can't
not watch the highlight for shinohoki
and yoshiro sexyalma that beautiful man
getting it done
and this is the end sequence i thought
it was going to be a bad fight for him
he was because you know i got his back
i was doing my research on one
championship last week i've seen akiyama
fighting hot sucking a little stiff you
know he's just older yeah 46 man that's
pretty up there yeah
yeah and then also shenya did get his
back for a long time
all right
yeah not even defending he was just
getting he was a punching bag at the end
of it
good for sexyama yeah and then um
oh let's look at this first this is john
wayne parr
um i guess michael shiovello you know
the voice yeah they called the voice
he surprised him with the video before
his fight with his family so i'll show
you real quick
good luck on your 100th win we believe
in you and you got this and get this
daughter yeah
uh i know you're going to get that 100
twin i can feel it love you so much you
got this
hey wayne i want to wish you good luck
and hopefully you get this hundredth win
no matter what we love you so much and
can't wait to see you in action
okay wait
for this fight okay it's the last fight
[Music]
thank you
he's such a badass man legend i love
that dude just the nicest person so
sweet yeah
and everybody got the win but that's all
good nah he went out great dude so
that's good
uh arrow posted this clip of akiano just
play real quick what is next for the
legend that is sexy yamaha
please get more sexy to the fight
yes
keep it sexy dude he can't help but look
at his [ __ ] hair dude he's perfect
god he's perfect his hair is ridiculous
yeah i wish i had his hair
and that gold skin dude
god dawg yeah and it's fashion we've
seen his fashion it's insane this is his
green suit for the press conference
his beanie best best man of all time in
mma hands down yeah and then joey b
joy bees up there but
not compared to sexy
it's like me and jared leto you know
what i'm saying yeah
okay so dana white posted this this is
pretty much
taken up all the new stations right it's
just will smith slapping chris rock yeah
so i watched the oscars live and so on
for those of you don't know i'm sure
most of you do
on the live broadcast of the oscars in
america they edit it out because there's
a there's a button where they can edit
things out just in case
yeah dump buttons what they call it yeah
just in cases 10 second delay
so we didn't really know what happened
on the on the broadcast
but
uh of course mark harley who spends more
time on his phone in the internet than
anybody i've ever met in my life and i
wish you would get off it a little bit
he goes holy [ __ ] juicy will smith
smacked chris rock
and when i first saw i'm like oh that's
it was this fake but then when will sits
down
and he's like keep my wife's name out
your f in mouth i'm like oh well
they're not going to script cuss words
because they can't play it no matter
what this is real
oh damn this is real
and then you watch it and you're going
to play it here chin yeah 47 million
views it's probably more now i got if i
refresh it
so before you go to this so this is will
walking up and slapping chris rock right
so before you play it
previous to this
there's a lot to go into here so
previous before this
chris rock who's a one of the greatest
comedians ever do it
he uh made a reference that about jada
pinkett smith that she uh he can't wait
to see gi jane tube because she has a
bald head right so gi jin shaves her
head
jada peekin smith has a condition of on
her scalp this condition i forget what's
called alopecia
where uh it like grows in patches and it
you know it's not good
so
he makes a joke about that um
and will when you watch it on the replay
is laughing he laughs at the joke but
jada piggy and smith is not laughing so
i think that's where will's like oh i
better do something or otherwise she's
going to hook up with lil wayne or some
[ __ ] so he goes up there we'll get to
that there's a reason why i did this
so he walks up there live during the
oscars
and slaps the [ __ ] out of chris rock
good technique too left hand is high for
the counter slap you know i think his
training from ali paid off a little bit
there but you see this play it chin
i hope we can play this in actual video
because twitter
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i janja
i'm going to okay
important oh okay he's
and then he has to do like the oscars
for the best documentary history of
television
he kind of stumbles through it he does
yeah uh which rightfully so you know um
you i i
you can't either either whatever your
perspective is on this entire situation
you can't have
people slapping other people on stage
you can't have comics getting assaulted
on stage with no repercussions
um
when it comes to this why because when i
watch the joke right i'm like a gi jane
joke that's not bad and then my friends
would defend and go well no she has a
condition i'm like oh [ __ ]
she have cancer what
man what are we talking about no she has
alopecia and you look like
okay you can't grow hair it's not like
she has freaking you know
aids or something like some real
condition or disease or cancer where it
would trigger will smith
and then the more you look into it you
go back 2016 when chris rock was the
host of the oscars
jada peak and smith
boycotted the oscars because there
wasn't enough african-american
representatives and i think there was
none it was like all white people so she
boycotted it so chris rock's
whole
bid on it which was hilarious he goes uh
and jpg smith isn't here tonight she's
boycotting the uh
the uh the uh the oscars for not enough
black representation
and he goes but she's on a tv show
he said that'd be like me boycotting
rihanna's panties because you you're
never invited
so he made those jokes about her
which again
not too bad yeah a horror i've
definitely heard worse
but i think this is accumulation of
since jada pika smith started red table
talk
the personal stories that she shares
about will and hers relationship and
this open relationship and she's had you
know she had that side piece augustus
whatever his name was and he's going on
family trips stuff like that
i think if you can be an open
relationship all good but especially
will smith who is so beloved people love
will smith we don't need to hear all
that [ __ ] so by her starting and i'm
glad she has her own thing that's great
it's a big show and i think they're
exclusively on facebook
but it's a big show and they have big
stars on there but by her being so open
and honest like some stuff we don't need
some [ __ ] is private men but it's
completely changed our perspective on
will smith and he's crying on there all
the time and you just see a different
side of will smith that we don't need to
see man so
it's kind of put a black eye no pun
intended but it's put a black guy in
will smith's kind of perception when it
comes to
you know the public because it's just
crazy [ __ ] man it's like dude stand up
for yourself
so i think he's been become this butt of
the joke and he's just taken all this
abuse all this abuse and chris rock in
2016 made those jokes about his wife and
there's all this abuse
i'm looking for the way it's it's like
he embodied the venus and serena
williams father's
[ __ ]
persona there you know because he's a
tough dude and he defends his family at
all costs you know that guy has his
faults that's for sure that the movie
definitely leaves some stuff out
um so i think you know maybe got too
into character and started to defend his
family but i think this goes back
even way before this and i think chris
rock was just kind of the escape goat
from all the years and all the [ __ ]
and all the
the you know making fun of will and the
memes and her coming out being open
relationship and all this stuff and the
kids and i think it was just
accumulation of all that stuff led to
this
because it's not in will's character
a part of me goes
and i truly believe this like we're in a
day and age now where with the internet
and you know people remain you know
unanimous and talk all this [ __ ] and all
that stuff and there's no repercussions
so part of me goes
play stupid games win stupid prizes like
i always say and chris rock played a
stupid game talk [ __ ] about will smith's
family and
won a stupid prize and got slapped and
it's the narrative now of the oscars
but as a comic like you can't have that
we can't have
people no matter if you're will smith
one of the most famous movie stars in
the world or some random joe schmoe at a
improv walking up on stage assaulting
the comics we just can't have that in
any facet also i'd be curious
you know a part of me feels like
obviously will's bigger than chris rock
i think chris rock is like
five seven 170 pounds five eight five
nine hundred seventy pounds will smith
is maybe six two hundred ninety two
hundred pounds so he's he's bigger not
like you know way bigger but he's
definitely a bigger man
and chris rock is obviously a an artist
and talented comic and smaller guy he's
fragile
so there's a little bit of bullying
going on here because if jason mamoa did
the same thing
would you have that same energy if jason
momoa came out there and torn to jada
pika smith you're gonna walk up there
and hit jason mamoa i don't think so my
man i bet you're gonna have that same
energy so
it's to me it's like you know a kid in
in elementary school who's getting
bullied by the bigger kid all the time
bullied all the time he's just taking in
months go by his ticket ticket and then
the skinny little twerp goes this kid
takes all this i'm gonna jump in here
and he goes yeah man you look like crap
and then finally that kid's getting
bullied on goes oh [ __ ] this dude and
takes that on him and he's been getting
months and months of abuse
to me this is will smith taking months
and months of abuse and finally sticking
up for himself
it's just not the right way to go about
it i i think you know hollywood has
failed with [ __ ] failed with a man
none of these guys are tough they're
just not none of them are anybody you
see on a movie they're not a tough guy
they're just not they play tough guys we
think they're tough guys but there's
also a reason why we don't know [ __ ]
about them that there's a reason for
that because they gotta sell tickets
they're not podcasters or stand-up
comics where i'll draw a line in the
santa i don't give a [ __ ] if you don't
like it a lot of people [ __ ] with it a
lot of people won't that's the world i
live in i love that world i'll get i
have a lot of haters i have more people
that love me that's the way this works
i'm gonna take a hard stance but you're
gonna know exactly where i stand will
smith can't john cena can't the rock
can't these guys in hollywood they can't
do that because they have to appeal to
the masses you have no you have no clue
about their political beliefs you have
no clue about their personal lives you
like i saw
years ago if you remember remember when
they're like tom hanks could win the
president uh of the white house right
now he could be president of america so
make people think he's trustworthy
why because he's forrest gump are you
your [ __ ] mind we don't know that
dude he's not getting on podcasts
ripping off you know ideas or opinions
he can't he has to sell tickets he has
to sell [ __ ] save it private ryan or
some [ __ ] if he gives you a hard stance
and doubles down on you know funding the
police or whatever it is or trump or
biden or kamala harris he loses half his
fan base that's why a lot of comics
don't get political did you separate the
room right right off the bat in half no
matter what the joke is
there's some guys who do it very well
and they do do that but then some
political comics like bill maher or
something like that they take a hard
stance and that's their crowd man and
they have a huge fan base but that's it
man they're gonna ride with their home
team
actors can't do that man they're not to
me i mean obviously they're
they inspire based off the movies the
roles that they play and the discipline
it takes to to act like that and i have
all the respect in the world for it's a
they're super talented and that's great
but as far as like real inspirational
motivational [ __ ] if you're looking
towards an actor to motivate you dude
you're barking up the wrong tree we
don't know these people that you can't
you just can't and that's part of the
reason you know i think you know a lot
of these actors don't come out and we
have no idea about what they personally
believe in because they they don't want
to cut their ticket sales in half
whether it's in china like john cena
remember when he messed up and started
speaking mandarin and [ __ ]
for the rock with with rogan remember
how fast he backtracked and was like no
[ __ ] he has tickets to sell dude that's
that's the name of their game we have no
idea
they're the softest people in the world
man [ __ ] hits the fan they will do
whatever it takes
to make sure that their credibility and
their likeness stays in good standing no
matter what it is they always walk the
middle there's never a real opinion out
of them
they're the fakest people in the world
we have no idea about them so for will
smith back to will smith
i think you know jadis pinkett smith
doing this red table talk
they give you a look inside will smith's
world which is
kind of weird to be honest i don't want
to know will smith is a cuck i don't
want to know that stuff i don't need
that
uh that's mike you know mike lowry or
whatever you know i don't need that in
my life i don't i don't need to know i
don't want to see him crying because the
girl was
flying a dude out on their family
vacation getting dick on the side while
the kids were at the pool
what
fresh prince of bel-air it's all good
baby get jiggy with it i don't need to
know all this stuff
but he became the butt of the joke
took it for years years years then
finally the smaller guy the innocent
comic not even a good i mean is whatever
joke it's not like he roasted the [ __ ]
out of her tell you what chris rock has
a chin though
chris rock has a chin on him
i can't imagine being slapped like that
in poor chris rock i mean this can be
talked about for how long
i was texting the group about it
i said
no in hollywood i've been my fair share
of hollywood parties man knowing
hollywood i will guarantee you at an
after party those two get together and
they're friends now i said i won't be
surprised if we get a picture of them
together you know will apologizing
something like that and sure enough p
diddy said that you know p diddy combs
or whatever was like yeah they're all
good they're they have to pry together
they're all good
okay you know i just think this was uh
just the final straw on the camel's back
that broke will smith because he's been
in so much [ __ ] being a [ __ ] and doing
all this stuff and let his girl get all
wild and was like god damn will you know
so i think finally stood up for himself
against the smaller guy
my question is would you have kept the
same energy with jason mamoa or the rock
i bet you won't do [ __ ] if he's one of
them you know
so
um
we're talking about it so most oscars
have been talked about people like you
know this this takes away from all the
hard work of the workers and [ __ ] hey
hate to tell you i watched the oscars it
was awful if this didn't happen we're
not talking about it at all this is the
best thing happened to oscars and i
don't know how long dude i don't know
how long in a long ass time because
we're all talking about it
um you know i also think just
from comic to comic i think too you know
amy schumer knows chris rock really well
really really well he's a mentor of hers
if let's say theo vaughn was hosting the
oscars could happen could happen he was
blowing up dude let's say theo's hosting
the oscars or any award show didn't have
to be the oscars and some dude slapped
theo
and i was like hosting it you know what
i'm saying like i was one of the
correspondents
i'm not just gonna
be like oh man like she came out was
like man i heard something happen what
happened everyone's laughing you know
what
your boy just got slapped dude defend
him
then you you use your skill set that
you've developed over the years and she
used to be an amazing roaster
tear into a man defend your friend
that's hollywood in a nutshell people
it's like you turn a light on
cockroaches they [ __ ] spread
all the ways there's no dif they're not
they don't have each other's back
because they they can't they they would
they they have pr people in there going
be careful this will stuff man you say
the wrong thing you know your movie
comes out next summer it could be a bad
look you know they can't they can't they
can't stick up for each other
end of the day a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
we all look up to them like they're
heroes they're not heroes man they're
fake people
that's why that happened it was just
years and years of abuse and will be in
the the
brunt of jokes left and right and
finally he's had enough and it was a
smaller guy and he could take advantage
of it
we're talking about it
it was so awkward yeah it was hilarious
my favorite is the woman who's from uh
black panther sent behind will smith
she's just like this the whole time just
like what and the [ __ ] is happening yeah
it's hilarious
it's all like again it's just such a
petty thing to do again part of me is
like oh you stuck it up for your family
good for you man there's
way better way sticker the other thing
is like you'd have to embarrass him do
it on national tv because it went in the
back you know and had an altercation
talk to a man-to-man that'd been cool
you know there's different ways to
handle it
but just as a comic myself
we can't have people going on stage
assaulting comics over jokes we can't
have it man
you know i'm glad chris rock is
impressing charges you know i wouldn't
either i just like what are you doing
dude it's just it's tough for chris
right for chris rocky in a weird
position i really really wish he went
back to his old new york coming up at
the stand and all that old chops and
really lit leaned into it lit him up
he would have said i mean not that he
needs any more help with his career but
if you would have torn them use that as
you know material and really
tore into the smith family and there's
so much content there that'd been the
move that would have went so viral for
chris rock we wouldn't be talking about
the slap we were talking about him
lighting will smith up that'd been the
move
or amy schumer could have done that
that's not hollywood man she's hollywood
now you know so there you go
what else got you i have a feeling he's
gonna do something chris yeah like
something i don't think so really
good it's not in their nature it's not
hollywood
i don't need to do anything i bet you
they come out together make a joke out
of it i bet you we get a video in the
next month
guarantee it
all right well and something was going
on because even before the award show
will smith took a picture with j p gets
smith and was like we got all dressed up
for chaos tonight like he knew something
was going down you know he knew chris
maybe from 2016 comments like he he had
that you know weird energy about him
and then he won an oscar and all of
hollywood's clapping for him for five
minutes let him talk it's like he just
assaulted a guy on stage
weird that's hollywood nutshell man
i want to be a vessel for love ten
minutes ago you just came up and slapped
somebody that's all for love dude you
just
it's the most
you know marquee slap of all time
you're known for slapping people more
than anything in this world now
and it takes away from it you know from
his award and then what's funny is you
remember in uh
something about mary when ben stiller
like the the brother like slammed him on
his head or
um you know he gets beat up they always
check on the guy that did it
like ben stiller's like all [ __ ] up
like you know he's like i was giving a
baseball he said can you let me in my
own house he's like what he just got his
ass whipped he's like what i'm the one
that get beat up
it's like this like bradley cooper and
samuel jackson and denzel washington
over to will smith to make sure he's
okay
chris rock's the one that got slapped
check out chris rockman [ __ ] will smith
right now
whole thing's so weird dude hollywood is
weird [ __ ] dude weird
what else you got all right okay so
someone is pressing charges and that's
colby covington this surprises me
uh
i i
you know i didn't think it'd be this big
of a deal obviously again circuit punch
breaking your tooth and i guess he
messed up his 90 000 rolex i know rolex
is that has to be some sort of weird
rolex it can't be like a daytona i don't
think he's into like vintage rolexes
some vintage ones go well over you know
60 70k 90k rolex it would have to be
some like diamond type of encrusted
rolex so that's weird to me but he was
saying the the rolex is messed up too
yeah fifteen thousand dollars worth of
damage sue must have scraped his rolex
um
yeah
um you know i i i was i was surprised
he's pressing charges just from
you know fired at a fighter things
happen
um and especially since remember they go
back man they were roommates best
friends press charges especially with
you know aggravated assault felony
criminal mischief
pre you know premeditated
felony criminal mischief a grade battery
you know if you press charges and he's
found guilty which he will be he's
looking at time dude do you really want
to put moswalt away for i don't know two
years three years over this
seems a little excessive i wish
you know someone could get uh
colby's there and just like don't press
charges dude don't do that man but also
for mozwarel again same [ __ ] he can't be
hidden people dude
especially in the sucker punch part
that's the psychopunch part's weird but
also he won mma fighting before i was
like oh i'm known for sucker punching
and this that which is so and dining and
dash or something like that yeah it's
it's so straight it's you know that's
not very gangster man
whatever you think is gangster that
would be the opposite where i come from
right yes and he's from like
you know miami they're pretty rough in
the streets there nobody respects the
guy who's sucker punching people never
another thing was mazda and i like
muslim man so i hate doing this
the thing is
bro you got paid for 25 minutes
to literally do whatever you want to
them besides illegal down knees or you
know 12 to six elbows outside that
whatever you want to do daddy you had 25
minutes you got paid for it on
pay-per-view worldwide tv you got your
ass whipped so i could see
you know if there's like an eye poke or
something like kobe cheated or something
like that and kobe be beat his ass for
25 minutes dude
and then you retaliate by
finding out what restaurants he at and
sucker punching them
i would respect it more if it's like
mazda all
knew kobe's at this restaurant was
pissed i was talking about his kids
which bet aspirin did and people have
done before
so and then you square up with them like
you approach a man-to-man you know i'm
like what are you doing are you fighting
the street
all right good still a little dicey but
you know and also you're making legit
money now moswell's never been bigger
even coming off a loss never been bigger
dude he's huge
you know you look at two to three years
in prison probably dude
it's so stupid and for what
you see did it feel good to suck punch
guy and clip his tooth
when you got literally destroyed for 25
minutes legally by commission
in the sport
to make sense
then i you know i don't i don't see
social media so i'm sure people like oh
miles at all badass this is where it
counts
you know how stupid of a take that is
it doesn't count anybody can sucker
punch anybody
i could walk up behind francis gegano
right now and sucker punch him who gives
a [ __ ] that is the most [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the world man nobody respects that if
you do my god man what are you doing
with your life if you respect the sucker
punch you're a sucker yourself man that
ain't the way to go about life man it's
just such [ __ ] [ __ ]
i just i don't get that why anybody in
the world respect any of this from will
smith to maz vidal
because will smith basically a cheap
shot too yeah
it's just [ __ ]
tendencies dude soft [ __ ] society's
getting softer and softer
anybody who's sticking up for will smith
or stake out from mosb it's just soft
betta soy boy [ __ ] dude
just soft man
i don't understand it
and maslow's been around too long and
finally dude you're making money you get
your fight league your tequila you're on
every billboard in miami everybody loves
you i love you and you do something like
this dude
and to the point of being a dad you got
kids what message i send to your kids
it's so stupid there was no upside to
this
what's the upside mosfet all
yes you sucker punched the guy when he
wasn't looking a guy who beat your ass
for 25 minutes just a few weeks
ago so fast forward 10 years from now
your kids are older they go dad how'd
that fight with cody comedian go there's
some bad blood there weren't you guys
like roommates and trademarks yeah yeah
yeah what happened
you know for five rounds i might have
won one but i got pretty beat up but you
know what i found out he's at a
restaurant and i walked up behind him
and sucker punched him kids are like
oh
that's cool i guess what happened there
i served five years that's why i wasn't
around
it's insane
nobody respects the guy who stuck a
bunch of people nobody respects the
bigger man who slaps a small comic it's
just all beta soy boy [ __ ]
i can't vouch for it man i don't ride
with it
all right so this writer for mm mania he
brought up something that
mazel can use for his defense
potentially it's the mutual combat rule
and the reason why he's saying that is
because there was an interview
um in 2020 with mike heck me fighting
and then this is what colby covington
said
kobe looks ridiculous
a hundred percent me
and street judas basketball are 100
percent gonna fight before it's all said
and done we we might fight a couple
times because if i see him in the street
it's going to be a fade session he's
going to get put on the concrete i'm
going to drop him on his [ __ ] head
and put stitches in the back of his head
it's not going to be nice mike i promise
you that and he knows that deep down
inside he knows but he's willing to take
a paycheck in the ufc to get his ass
well because he knows the ufc is going
to pay his [ __ ] medical bills
but besides that if he if we fight in
the street i'm going to drop him on his
[ __ ] head and he's never going to be
the same person again because he's going
to be concussed the concrete's going to
mess with him
and i'll probably kick his teeth into
while i'm at it
just because he's a piece of [ __ ] i mean
i mean the guy's claiming i mean he's
the sucker punch king you know he's
claiming for being out at denny's and
being the diamond dash king dude
you're a piece of [ __ ] man you're dining
and dashing and single mothers that are
working at denny's because you know
they're trying to put food on the table
for their child and
you're bragging about being proud of
dining and dashing on them dude the guys
the lowest scum denominator of earth and
he's the fakest piece of [ __ ] he turned
his back on me for money and his
management team
and people are gonna find out the real
truth about him i mean he's gonna get
exposed soon i know so much about him
and it doesn't make sense to come out
again it'll all be built up
i think too but it's a weird defense
because i mean that's like the only
thing you could do yeah it's gonna be
tough in the court of law too because
you know he's talking about a street
fight yeah i'm not getting sucker
punched exactly because it wasn't a
fight so technically
um i'm sure the defense team's gonna eat
that up like yeah he's talking about a
fight fight they screw off in a fight
fight also
um
if we're gonna go off of
what colby kevin says or any fighter for
that matter
you know it's like how many fighters
have you heard say what sean strickland
say i want to kill a guy in the ring or
some [ __ ] like that so it's like
they're selling they're they're
entertainers colby more so than anybody
talks so much [ __ ] to get you to hate
him so you tune in to see if he loses he
just happens to be one of the best
welterweights on the planet he's tough
to [ __ ] beat unless your name's
camaro hoosman or hamzad for that matter
but um
so it's give me a tough tough leg to
stand on man you know he talked so much
[ __ ] yeah and also but that and also the
mutual combat legal uh in florida
um so in florida mutual combat is
recognized defense because both parties
consent to being touched
as an unsure conscious of an altercation
both parties must be at fault and the
defendant must not be primary aggressor
initiate the fight what she did which is
the primary aggressor then she just
doesn't get a hold up in any facet yeah
hey man i just really hope colby drops
the charges like i hope they settle out
of court might as well i was like yo
i'll get your new rolex just don't make
me surprised i got kids man and i don't
want to see mozvale go to [ __ ] prison
or stupid [ __ ] it's a mistake and you
know in the same time but again
kobe talked so much [ __ ] finally you
know it comes back to haunt you a little
bit man but it shouldn't shouldn't be
sucker punch that's the thing i hate
yeah yeah if it was a straight up fight
equal fight on the street like he's
walking this car in mazel what's up now
[ __ ] it's all good you're talking all
that stuff about the street fight here i
am
all good you guys figure it out yeah
hopefully no one gets killed but you
know i don't want that but yeah go ahead
and fight there if you want
all right
uh khabib had a take on this as well he
wrote this on his twitter
uh khabib if you are stronger than
someone inside the octagon it does not
mean that you can insult his children no
one has the right to insult someone's
family once you have gone down this path
then ready to back up your words you
were attacked by a professional fighter
the same as you are your own size and
you go press charge against him to the
police i think all welterweight should
refuse to fight colby just don't accept
fights with him let him sit without a
fight it will probably significantly
affect him and all the fighters who even
think of insulting families who who has
provoked the fighters to look for
someone in restaurants to deal with him
the the only thing again uh oh kenneth
owens yes
uh right the stone [ __ ] didn't call for
a boycott he better go buy a [ __ ] hat
and join the nba mma is a man's sport
she went hard canis goes hard in the
paint
yeah for khabib i i just again
i i'm with khabib if it was a regular
even street fight if colby was aware
what was going on
cool man you guys handle it how you want
to handle it do you have all this bad
blood and it leaks out and outside the
octagon you got to do this all right do
it man
but to sucker punch another man is the
biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] in the world dude
there's nothing softer there's nothing
gangster about it there's nothing tough
about it mazel hadn't trained since he
was 14 in the backyards of miami in
order to become a better sucker puncher
anybody can psycho punch anybody little
christian meatball come up right now and
come behind me when i'm not ready and
sucker punch me it's gonna it's not good
man yeah it's just [ __ ] tendencies dude
yeah for khabib too it's like what are
you doing dude
be always trying to make the headlines
with hot takes right yeah and i love
khabib but that ain't the hill to die in
boycott fighting him it's like
i got idea i got an idea khabib why
don't you come out of retirement and try
to be colby
why don't you do it the legal way talk
then you know khabib's
you know he's keeping himself relevant
he has his fight league and stuff like
that and he said you know if
if
uh conor beats uh marcus i'll come out
of retirement all good i like that
we keep the same energy here though if
you don't like kobe so much
come out retirement fight them
beat them up you can do it legally you
don't have to worry about getting sucker
punch or pressing charges fight colby
legally
do that that'd be cool you're a fighter
that's how this should be handled
you guys can do this legally make money
there's no reason to do it in the
streets
no reason especially no reason to sucker
punch somebody never
but for again khabib i'm with you if it
was an even fight you know yeah okay
then it's all good yeah
um you mentioned khabib's fight league i
read something where dan hardy said he
might be actually going there okay
google fc just rumors
all right um there's more details that
came out with the chael's son and stuff
he's hit with 11 charges for the alleged
fight and this is coming from like you
said before the las vegas review
whatever las vegas journal and the guy
that's suing the guy suing but the guy
dropped the charges originally that's
our heard right what that's what we
heard at first yeah and then you bring
them back i guess so
uh so we obtained videos strongly after
alleged altercation showing sonam being
lewd away in handcuffs
as previously reported someone had
initially been slapped with five battery
citations over the alleged fight but a
judge in nevada dismissed the case in
january after the clark county district
attorney told us the citations no still
appeared failed to comply with the legal
requirements as set forth by nevada law
so they didn't go through with it
and
here are some
some of the details
but this is just from the las vegas
review journal yeah
well so that's where the report came out
but it's the guy that's suing this is
the guy's name is christopher steele
stealth flug or stealth flug yeah still
still i don't know
before i read this
realize one thing i'm sure mr stelfag
has his version of the story jail has
his virgin right there's two sides and
there's the truth i think there's
somewhere in the middle here right
uh civil lawsuit was also filed by
christopher and julie's stuff claiming
seemingly intoxicated sonan knocked a
drink out of his hand and then attacked
him without uh provocation or any
communication whatsoever so i was
wandering the hallway of the four
seasons hotel next to mandalay bay
barefoot wearing a torn bloody t-shirt
at the time
um then this man goes on say the the
accuser says i just want people to know
it was totally unprovoked attacked
he told the las vegas review journal we
were just walking in our room to plan a
sushi dinner we did nothing wrong this
guy went on a crazy rampage
god i just
have a hard time believing that that is
not in jail sonan's dna
the lawsuit says another hotel guest had
to stop someone from choking mr step
plug only to get attacked and elbowed in
the face
so and then alleged attacked the wife
throwing against one punch her in the
face
the filings allege that several hotel
employees were also assaulted by so
including security guard that was needed
in the face another who was kicked in
the chest there's so much stuff going on
here it's insane
keep going down uh-huh that's the older
one yeah keep going down here
[Music]
um
yeah i it's just a lot to take in right
yeah um and said they are they had minor
injuries
my question would be
chael's selling every bit of probably
230 pounds
he hit this
i'm assuming she's standard sized woman
i don't know 5 6 130 pounds average
woman
if chelsea slammed against one socked
her in the face minor injuries
okay
and the man so he he really punched him
in the face
and then the guy who was elbowed on the
ground from jail sonin
minor injuries
okay and they said hotel employees got
into it so i i haven't heard anything
about hotel employees this first time
i've heard of it yeah also
i stay at four seasons nice hotel
where's the security footage it's in the
hallway there's there's cameras
everywhere where's the camera this is
very easy to solve
where's the four seasons hotel security
footage
i'd love to see it
um again i think there's this guy's
version of story tails and the truth
somewhere in the middle i wasn't there i
don't know clearly chael's a close
friend i'll defend trail until something
else comes out
um
this is how i operate yeah you know i
don't know what happened there knowing i
have a hard time
hard time a guy has no history of
violence outside the outgun that
randomly picked this innocent family and
punched both them in the face i have a
very hard time believing that
very very difficult time believing that
and if he did
minor injuries
that's okay
that's where it's a little weird there
um
again i just i need i need more
information before you know but you know
i don't know this whatever his name is
you know i don't know this guy i know
chael and i'm pretty well joe's a very
good person very good dad very good
person
i'm gonna need more i i i need more
evidence before i take this guy's word
i've never heard of
um you know crapping on chelsea
the story sounds insane too all that
chaos it just sounds pretty crazy insane
all right so jon jones tweeted something
then deleted it he mentioned your name
is uh name in it as well
so
i don't think he added you come on dude
i need my followers up so
oh so you mentioned dan hooker and you
because you guys are critical of him
obviously like everyone was about the
whole wife
hitting alleged wife hitting incident
even though the kids reported all that
stuff whatever yes yeah
uh so this is ch uh this is jon jones
talking yep and he deleted it he said
dan hooker bro how did why do people
delete stuff i don't know because it
lives in forever right now yeah i don't
know so but dan hooker brendan schaub is
this what you guys are jumping down my
throat about and what's it was talking
about this new these new details about
chelsea so then you go sorry but man
everyone their mom covered my story when
i was an [ __ ] in las vegas stoner
allegedly attacks his wife another woman
along uh with like five men and crickets
no not crickets not crickets um i don't
i don't know john person i don't i don't
know him like i know chill i talk to
chill all the time i i've worked with
jail trained with jail for years i know
jail very well i don't know john that
well um john has a history a history
yeah a deep
long rap sheet history of making some
mistakes
um
jump and what did i jump down his throat
about when his stuff came out the first
time this stuff came out with the the
kids the wife the yeah man when i hear
you know your daughter something like
that on the security guard don't let us
go back up there don't let me you know
that's where it affects me as another
dad
um
i wouldn't say i jump down your throat
trust me i don't jump down your throat
it's hard to defend when you know your
wife and kids are involved i can't
defend you i don't know what happened
there
um
there's just a there's a there's a
pattern here a child doesn't have a
pattern so it's tough to defend jon
jones i don't jump down his throat i
think people make mistakes
um and i you know i'm very forgiving but
definitely don't jump down his throat
you know when you when you hear that
stuff
about john it's obviously way easier to
believe than chael sonin for for a
reason
i get you know fighters are sensitive so
dan hooker bench
dan hooker goes after him yeah dan
hooker oh yeah
a little bit i i don't light him up
so dan hooker posted on march 27th
explain how this makes you any less less
of a piece of a [ __ ] and what do you
post that with that message
yeah yeah it's not like well look what
chael did
well no listen i'll tell you right now
if you show me a video from the
from the freaking four seasons of chill
hitting a woman or his wife
no one will jump more down his throat
than me i will light his ass up here on
the shop show i will never talk to him
again you touch a woman i'm out dude
that goes for john jones
chael sonnen anybody
anybody
i don't [ __ ] with in any capacity
so it's not like well where where's this
keep the same energy with chill
and i will if it comes out and the four
seasons like yeah here's the video we
obtained you know tmz is like here's the
video and chael's just going freaking
berserker bane mode yeah i'm out dude
i'm not defending that
right now the only thing i'm defending
is i know chael's character i know what
type of dad he is what kind of husband
he is what kind of person he is i've
been in the locker room with chael
sonnen i've been in training camps chael
sonin i've worked with chael sonnen when
we both retired i know chael very well
this is not in his demeanor to do this
so i definitely have skeptical hippo
eyes based off my personal experience
with chael sonnet when it comes to jon
jones
there are many examples of him making
terrible life decisions that have
affected his career in a very negative
way so when reports come out it's hard
to defend because there's a rap sheet
there with chelsea it's easy to defend
because i know him personally and
there's no rap sheet there this is
surprising to anybody involved with jail
sonin in every capacity that's the
difference
but jump down your throat john now oh
come on dude and i still i still have
you pound for pound number one by far i
still think you're gonna be the
heavyweight champ of the world i even
after all this dude and i said i'd never
defend you after this after all this i
still want you to be the heavyweight
champion the world i still think you're
me heavyweight champion of the world i
really do man
i think outside of
the octagon he's been out for what damn
near two years now i think outside that
his personal life is in shambles you
know he's talked about being lonely in
the house and it's like yeah dude you're
playing this game it's caught up with
you man it sucks to see i don't want
that for him i hope he figures it out i
hope maybe losing his family gets him
you know sober and gets him to figure
things out it sounds like he said he's
been sober right last time
so you know i'm here the entire step
we're rooting for you man
not jumping down your throat but when
that stuff comes out and there's legit
reports that your kids are saying you
know don't don't let my dad back in the
room and stuff like that we got problems
man it's from one dad to another
it's a problem dude that's not good my
man
so yeah trail's much easier to defend
and the end of the day i know jail very
well i don't know john
all right
um
another arrest
but this is very nice
this is very like not that big a deal
though but conor mcgregor was arrested
and his car was seized because he was
driving a little crazy according to the
guardian how crazy was he driving they
impounded his car yeah he's going like
150 miles an hour who knows
but uh yeah so bentley continental worth
more than 187 000 that means it's used
because this coach about 300 grand brand
new uh mcgregor was probably polar
police then arrested and charged with
several driving offenses along with his
car being pounded by authorities who's
eventually hit with a dangerous driving
charge which comes with a potential
financial plan as well as possible six
months in prison he won't serve now
um
his vigo was returned him
mcgregor was driving to the gym when he
was stopped by uh
the cops for alleged road traffic
violence [ __ ] violations he passed the
drug and alcohol test taken at the
station which is how was he driving
i don't know but that seems like the car
right there right bentley yeah yeah
that's a new bentley convertible
yeah yeah crazy i'd be driving sober for
them to give they get arrested for
impounded jesus christ dude now vin
diesel
who knows what he was doing
i thought this was just funny because
you know conor mcgregor and jared have
been going back and forth they
jared basically agreed to play conor in
a movie and then conor said come over
here and i'll let's you know we can work
on my character he's like yeah he'll go
for it so after that came out um
nate diaz said wolverine could play his
part in that movie wolverine being jack
jack
hugh jackman hugh jackman yeah
awesome little i'm ready to come and
practice the part with me
um and then nate diaz said wolverine
could play my part so we can see him
beat jared leto's ass that'd be a that'd
be fun right
and then uh connor responded the kid
that played heisenberg's son breaking
bad is who will play you virtually
identical so i had to i saw breaking bad
a long time i've never seen it yet so
heisenberg's son
[Music]
is this kid i guess he has cerebral
palsy okay speech difficulties and
impaired motor control okay that stuff
yeah a pretty big dig by connor there
yeah
uh and also on nate diaz he requested
his release he's been doing this before
but he attacked dana white and hunter
campbell on this as well
because i apologize for asking online
but you don't give me a fat asset asap i
got [ __ ] to do
and [ __ ] be crying because they
got get dropped from the uc i can't pay
out of this [ __ ]
yeah i'm with nate on this i know he's
asking for a fight and they're just not
giving it to him yeah i don't know what
they're waiting for the dustin poirier
fight made all the sense in the world
dustin wants it i i'm with nate it's
like dude let me fire [ __ ] let me go
and then jake paul now is like dude let
him out of his contract so we can fight
him they'll make all the money in the
world oh yeah what's interesting now
because jake paul's out there the ufc
knows if they release conor or jake i'm
sorry conor or nate it's on because
those boys can go over and make all the
money you know so the ufc is kind of in
a tough spot you gotta fight nate dude
yeah
good for nate
and speaking of jake paul he announced
that he announced that he's coming out
coming back
august 6 to fight someone i wonder who
it is on august 6th august and he puts
6-0 so this august i wonder who it is
because jake's he's past the point of
youtubers
like he wants to be taken seriously he's
beat woodley twice now
tommy fury fight's still out there he
for jake he's a little different than
his brother he's not just trying you
know he's not going to fight you know a
ksi or something another youtuber like
he's legit you know kind of getting
there and if he were to fight a youtuber
it goes two steps back so for him i
wonder who it is i know it should
probably be tommy fury right i would
assume it'd make sense
but that's fine this summer ish yeah
that's cool
this was pretty crazy so patty pimple
was on the barstool sports podcast and
he revealed that he made 12 and 12. so
12 yeah 12 to fight and 12 to win for
his last fight
you know he's
a newer fighter you know
it's weird to have him at 12 and 12
because of the hype coming in right
so 12 and 12 i mean 24 grand after taxes
you have the 50 000 bonus
um i would assume that uh
they they step his pay up it's weird to
have him at 12 and 12 because he could
sell out arenas before you get to the
ufc and they know that he's super
popular too so that is kind of
surprising and i'm the people were
saying like he's they're not sure if
he's supposed to say this but
whatever he should 12 and 12 is insane
that's terrible money for what he's
doing especially the
the eyeballs that he brings i mean
to be fair he's probably the most
underpaid guy in the ufc as far as his
market value to his compensation he's
probably the most underpaid fighter in
ufc
now the ufc it's you know
you've got to win to get to the next
contract but you're dealing with a
little there has to be some caveat there
you're dealing with a different animal
clearly the kids 12 and twelve who make
that yeah that's crazy that looks crazy
i mean he gets paid more from barstool
than he does fighting inside the octagon
that's a problem
how about the up his pay after this
yeah i guess so after every fight can
you negotiate a contract or if you're a
contractor in a contract
it's tough man um you could be
undeniable the ufc is kind of going like
hey dude we gave you a layup yeah ufc
london men you were you know you were
[ __ ] minus 600.
we'll give you a contract but then we
ain't protected anymore which is stupid
because the bigger he gets more money
there
but it's kind of like with sugar shawn
o'malley who
almost pot i think i can say this he
negotiated his contract himself with no
lawyers president or managers with dana
white
recently so i'm curious how that went
down
um
but sugar shawn was smart about it
because he's like do you want me to
fight these top contenders and he's at
that level now right he's there to make
the leap um he's like you got to pay me
you know i'm not fighting these guys for
my standard contract and ufc he was like
yeah all right cool but he is once
once you do get that big payday you're
you're fighting the the boys the real
badasses
so for patty it's kind of a double-edged
sword because you want to get experience
in the ufc he does have experience in
you know that other organization outside
the ufc which is big was it cage of fury
something like that
cage warriors he's huge in that right
theory is it cage of fear it's cage
favorite of video games i forgot yeah
that's fabulocation it's a movie
um
but so you should be careful what you
asked for you know because it's a
marathon not a sprint so
you know if patty makes these crazy
six-figure demands all right well then
we're gonna have to put you on
pay-per-views and
headline fight night you're fighting
five rounds like we have to get our
money's worth man but you're fighting
you know we can't have you versus some
random guy on a fight night main event
anymore you're fighting the real deal so
if you're ready for that all right we'll
entertain it so it's it's a tough road
man you know i don't know the right
answer there but he's making money he's
getting six figures from barstool so i
mean outside i'm sure he's doing really
well yeah
so it's like keep doing that keep
building your name you keep giving them
you know formal opponents you can kind
of rush through and create this you know
huge star because
just for for patty hopefully someone's
in his air i'm sure he believes he's
ready to be world champion he's not he's
just not there's nothing wrong with that
he's had what two fights in the ufc and
he's been hit in both fights so
hopefully someone's in his ears like
dude slow down slow down slow down man
we'll get there
you're being compensated outside let's
let's chill a little bit man because 55
is i mean dude you know you need to
fight a top 40 guy
the 155 is stacked yeah you better be
ready because you're going to follow
that top 10 ranking fast
they start throwing you those [ __ ]
top 20 guys it's it's give me a
different story man
just slow down young man yeah slow down
you're doing well huge fans here
okay so we talked about paige van zandt
signing with the aew the wrestling
league yeah i thought she was done
fighting apparently they allowed her in
that contract to still continue bkfc so
she's gonna now
headline uh bkfc card in london
that girl's making money july 9th
i wonder if she's going to fight no
point announced yet but yeah she's
headlining good for her man i'm a fan of
paige who's not
definitely needs to win huh
oh yeah she has to win or not she's
still crying i'll just stay in the aw
yeah whatever
uh this is pretty dope
so sean strickland wow he's fighting
alex
yeah
july 30th ufc 267 hopefully the main
events jon jones and stipe on that can
you imagine with pierre is interesting
too i told you guys he he's he's about
now especially you beat sean strickland
which i don't think he beats him but if
he were to beat sean strickland what's
strickland right
five or four let me see
i need to what a jump up for him
before and they have paul cost that
fortune which is weird they have a bunch
of fun
that makes sense just do four five six
huh yeah um
so this dude's jumping from
what's he right is he in the top 15
uh-uh so he's going from on rank to
number four that's why it's a trippy
fight
well
all the ufc is doing is putting them on
the fast track because they the
narrative of him versus izzy and he beat
izzy in kickboxing that narrative
is such a good sell because is he
he doesn't have a lot of people to fight
he's cleared up the division kind of
there's nothing for him to do man so
this would be the one thing like all
right well he gets past if he starts his
strickland will give him a title shot
it's a better narrative
i don't think he beats sean strickland i
just don't that's tough that's a lot to
chew off for that man
i don't think he wants those problems
with this you know is he's you know we
can talk about the kickboxing the
knockout sure man you know how long ago
that was and this is the ufc dad yeah
it's mma
uh another great fight santiago
ponzinibio versus my michelle
the crazy dude that jumps around all the
time
yeah maybe i'll need to win i need to
win
and you already mentioned already this
dave's infiguredo and brandon raynor
four that's being confirmed july is
about to get toasty yeah we have some
good fights in july yeah this summer
should be awesome for mma
um so we talked about this before yar
saw this killer in bellator he was
supposed to fight
michael venom page in may but then he
decided to stay in ukraine to help
defend his homeland badass badass for
sure and now
mvp has a new opponent
uh this guy named storly which he's a
badass too his only loss was actually
that guy
oh split decision too yeah so he's got a
tough fight out of the way
yeah it's tough for mvp man yeah but
that's friday may 13th what a badass
stand back fighting for his hometown
scary but so so cool to hear that kind
of so michael van page will still fight
for championship gold
because did they strip homeboy for
fighting ukraine maybe this is like an
interim bill i'm guessing it might be an
interesting interim worldwide
championship okay
he's gonna say jesus christ
fighting for his country hell no
oh that's a fun fight yeah so that yawn
racket's a great fight yeah
when's that may mm-hmm and that's ariel
five rounds so it's a main event tonight
that's a fun fight
um let's go to
i thought this was pretty interesting
that cause hazmat was just saying like
yeah even if he beats gilbert burns he
should get the title shot but if they
want connor he understands because he
you know whoever's more famous he's
smart dude yeah he gets it
good for him
all right and i oh this is the last one
then so melvin manoff
apparently these three burglars tried to
rob his home once when he was out of
town and they came back again when he
was home jesus christ so he found that
or saw them took his car chased them
down pinned all three of them down to
the cops came by and there's actual
picture of it here too
these three dudes
pinned down a few burglars dead held
them down until the police arrived top
fighter was injured in his hand yeah
from beating their ass yeah god why
would you rob his house what if he like
kicked any of them i don't do that he
could do anything and how do three of
you get caught by one man oh you're
[ __ ] chasing down the car yeah i got
him i don't know how how do the three of
you get busted
one of you couldn't run away
so he has a messed up hand now but uh
his fight with romero is supposed to be
may 6 so who knows that's we're saying
now who knows if he's gonna be able to
make that fight
few months about a month this shirt
april good on man off he's a badass
yeah is that it brother that's it
all right kids hope you enjoyed this
week's episode of the shop show
um that's about it man thank you guys
for listening thanks for subscribing
liking everything we got a busy april
coming up man next fight companion will
be april 9th
uh april 9th a big day because we have
the thick mudder at 10 30 a.m in san
bernardino california it's at 10 30 a.m
if you go to toughmudder.com you see the
thick boy
group at 10 30 a.m use promo code thick
boy and you get 10 off the sign up fee
which actually really helps on that
thing and we're offering the 15k which
your thick friend here does with my crew
mark harley and the boys and we're also
offering a 5k which is uh a lot shorter
right so there's 5k 15k and i tell
everybody this you don't have to be
freaking
uh
lance armstrong to run this thing i'm
telling you it's about getting through
it it's not about sprinting everywhere
casey's done it before it's just a good
time we bond together we have a great
time you can order your official thick
mutter shirt from thickboy.com right now
i would get on it asap if you want to
end time for the races you'll see the
whole squad rocking the new thick boy
tough mudder shirt it's a bit about
right now i will see you april 9th not
only in san bernardino uh for the tough
mudder the thick mud at 10 30 a.m but
also that night live from the thick boys
studio for the big ufc pay-per-view and
we got a squad lined up for that special
cobb ass fight companion um as far as
the road goes
taking a little two weeks little loose
seat not even two weeks man because
april 6 uh hollywood improv shop and
friends that would be our seventh
sold-out show eighth eighth sold-out
show get tickets right now don't wait if
you wait to the day of we see all those
dm people complaining they can't get in
it
they can't grow the venue any bigger so
it's uh one show one not only with the
squad deleah brian chappelle david lucas
the monsters are all there think boy
style hollywood improv april 6 wednesday
night 8 p.m
and then the thick boy tour continues
april 14th through the 16th stand up
live phoenix arizona i'll be balls deep
in jt wings
and then austin is austin texas april
22nd through the 23rd the moon tower
comedy festival and i have a very
special announcement dropping on
freaking april 28th i can't wait it's a
big deal for your boy uh that's it man
if you want tickets go to fatkz.com or
thinkboy.com has them and uh i will see
you guys around man thanks for listening
thanks for watching be safe be nice to
each other like subscribe love ya i'm
out